with this historical and literary
background in mind let us turn our
attention to the distinctive features of
this story itself here is the beginning
of the story in the new nrsvue
translation
when God began to create the heavens and
the Earth the Earth was complete chaos
and darkness covered the face of the
deep
while a wind from God swept over the
face of the waters then God said let
there be light and there was light
and God saw that the light was good
and God separated the light from the
darkness
God called the light day and the
Darkness he called night
and there was evening and there was
morning the first day
you may be familiar with certain other
translations of the Bible that render
the initial phrase here as a separate
sentence in the beginning God created
the heavens and the Earth period
however I prefer the interpretation of
this phrase as a temporal Clause when
God began to create
because it better fits the literary
pattern of ancient creation accounts
that we have seen especially those from
Mesopotamia
just as the atra hasis Epic begins when
Gods like men and a pneuma Elish begins
when the heavens above had not been
named
so the seven day creation Story begins
when God began to create
this understanding also makes better
sense of the grammar of the Hebrew
original in my view
in any case the tenor of the text from
the very beginning is consonant with
what we know of other ancient creation
accounts
the allusions to Mesopotamian creation
stories don't end there
note the mention of the heavens and the
Earth in the first line which is of
course a common way across the ancient
world of referring to everything that
exists the universe
this pair is also invoked in the first
two lines of enuma Elish when the
heavens above had not been named nor the
Earth beneath been called by name
moreover just as a pneuma aylish
imagines an initial state of chaos
represented by roiling Waters
so the seven day Genesis creation also
mentions a complete chaos Hebrew tohu
vavohu
as well as Darkness covering the face of
the deep and Waters
indeed the word translated deep is the
Hebrew term to home which is
etymologically related to the Acadian
term Tiamat as the name of the
primordial saltwater goddess of a pneuma
Elish
an observation that's possible because
both Hebrew and Acadian belong to the
Semitic language family
the point here isn't that the two
stories are identical because they
certainly represent different accounts
of how creation takes place but that
they share a common background a joint
conceptual vocabulary for talking about
creation
they make use of the same symbols and
shared patterns of how creation is
understood but tell distinct stories
with those symbols
what is particularly distinct about this
Israelite seven-day creation story is
the role of a single God Hebrew Elohim
who brings all things into existence
instead of a gendered primordial pair
like an enuma ailish in which the waters
themselves have generating power
here we have a single deity that's
present above the waters which are
relegated to the background and
diminished in importance
in fact it's details like these that led
some interpreters to see the story as a
subtle critique or correction of the
official Babylonian creation account of
a pneuma aylish
it's as if the Israelite author is
saying no the creation of heavens and
the Earth did not happen the way the
Babylonians understood it it actually
happened this way with the Israelite God
as the Creator
the means by which Elohim creates
that is by speaking things into
existence let there be light is actually
reminiscent of ancient Egyptian
conceptions particularly that of Pata in
the Memphis theology as we mentioned in
a previous lecture
but as a further distinction from both
Egyptian and Mesopotamian conceptions
Elohim is not the parent of a series of
other generations of gods Elohim is the
singular God or at least the only
Supreme deity that is of relevance to
Creation
everywhere in the story where there
might be hints of another god-like being
such as the waters or the Deep to home
the sun moon and stars which are viewed
as deities and other ancient near
Eastern cultures or the great creatures
of the sea in verse 21 the importance of
that being is diminished relative to the
Creator deity
I also mentioned that the Israelite
Priestly source is characterized by an
emphasis on order in its presentation of
things and this text is a prime example
of this
the progression of creation acts over
the seven days follows a very structured
pattern in which days one through three
and days four through six form two
distinct groups
days one through three involve acts of
Separation that is taking something that
is relatively disordered and producing
more order by distinguishing one part of
it from another
so light is separated from Darkness on
day one
the waters above are separated from the
waters Below on day two
and the dry land is separated from the
Seas on day three
days four through six on the other hand
involve acts of filling the creation of
things to populate the ordered
structures that have been established on
days one through three in corresponding
fashion so day four involves the
creation of Lights the Sun the moon the
stars in the sky thus filling the
structure provided on day one
day five involves the creation of sea
creatures and birds thus filling the
waters above the sky and the waters
below
and day six has the creation of all land
animals including humans thus populating
the dry land
everything adheres to a perfectly
symmetrical pattern
all this is capped off by the seventh
day when God rests Hebrew Shabbat this
is the word from which the Jewish term
Sabbath is derived God rests from the
work of creation not out of exhaustion
but as an expression of satisfied
completion
the overall pattern of three plus three
plus one makes the chapter resemble a
textual representation of a well-built
physical structure
another notable feature of this creation
story is the place of humans in the
overall picture
we have noted in relation to the Stories
We examined previously how human beings
don't typically have a particularly
exalted role
in a pneuma ailish the creation of
humans is a bit of an afterthought and
their exclusive purpose is to worship
the Gods
is humans are integral to the story but
only because of their crucial role in
taking over the manual labor of the
lower gods and subsequently it's their
noise making that prompts the plagues
and then the flood
by contrast the seven day creation story
puts humans at the center of it all
in an elevated position as the
culmination of creation
the relevant passage is as follows then
God said let us make humans in our image
according to our likeness
and let them have dominion over the fish
of the sea and over the birds of the air
and over the cattle and over all the
wild animals of the earth and over every
creeping thing that creeps upon the
Earth
so God created humans In His Image in
the image of God he created them
male and female he created them
God blessed them and God said to them
be fruitful and multiply and fill the
Earth and subdue it and have dominion
over the fish of the sea and over the
birds of the air and over every living
thing that moves upon the Earth
first the fact that the creation of
humanity takes place as the final Divine
act on day six speaks to how humans
serve as the Pinnacle of creation both
in terms of status and responsibility
note that humans are the only creatures
in the entire story that are given a
command to rule over the other animals
but there's an additional dimension of
this that relates especially to the
Priestly background of the story
I hinted earlier that there's an implied
analogy between the entirety of creation
and a temple Abode in the story a number
of details I've mentioned already
support this idea from the ordered three
plus three plus one structure of the
days with days one through three
balancing days four through six to the
expression of satisfied completion and
rest on the seventh day
but perhaps the clearest indication of
this idea is the way that the creation
of the human is described in the passage
God says let us make humans in our image
according to our likeness
the first person plural hour might seem
a bit puzzling on the surface but this
is best understood as the so-called
plural of majesty like the Royal we used
by kings and queens of England
but the key lies in the terms our image
and our likeness which in the first
instance describes some fundamental
resemblance between the appearance of
the human being and that of God in other
words the human being is a copy a
physical representation of God
moreover the term translated image is
the Hebrew word selim which is commonly
used also to designate an idol a cult
statue that is the physical
representation of a God that one would
find in an ancient Temple
the implication here then is clear
the human being is the cult statue of
God of Elohim in the temple that is the
heavens and the Earth
in a world when the Jerusalem Temple no
longer stood when it seemed that
Israel's God no longer had a house in
which to be worshiped this story offers
a complete reorientation
the whole world is God's Abode and human
beings are God's image being the fullest
representation of the divine presence in
the world a role usually reserved for
kings in the ancient near East
that also aligns with the responsibility
of humans in the story to have dominion
over the rest of the created order
one finds a similar idea articulated in
another text from the Hebrew Bible from
after the Babylonian exile that is
Isaiah 66 verse 1.
thus says the Lord heaven is my throne
and the Earth is my footstool so what
kind of house could you build for me
what sort of place for me to rest
notice here that the body of the Lord is
imagined as filling the entire heavens
and the Earth Heaven being the throne
chair and the Earth being the footstool
we find depictions of the throne and
footstool fairly commonly in the
iconography of Syria Palestine in the
late bronze and iron ages to represent
human Kings roughly contemporaneous with
the time period of the emergence of
Israel and the early writing of the
biblical texts
but here that metaphor is extended to a
god whose parameters are comparable to
the very limits of the known world
and so because of this no house that any
human could build is adequate for him
within biblical scholarship this part of
the book of Isaiah is widely recognized
to have originated after the Babylonian
exile arguably after the composition of
Genesis 1 itself
if so then this text May in fact
represent a poetic reflection on the
notion articulated in the seven day
creation story revealing the spread of
this renewed conception of God Among the
literary Elite that produced the Hebrew
Bible
In Sum the six days of creation with the
acts of Separation at a filling
represent the making of the heavens and
the Earth as the Abode of God
in other words we not only have a
creation story we also have a story
about the building of a palace Temple
while in stories like enuma Elish we
have a building of a palace to culminate
the achievement of creation
hear the very creation is the palace and
Temple the house of God
God creating the world in six days is in
itself the establishment of a palace and
Temple for himself
furthermore it's human beings who
function as the embodiment of the divine
presence in this Temple of Heaven and
Earth as the cultic image of God
recognizing these and other literary
features enables us to understand the
special appeal of this text that helped
to make it one of the most enduring
visions of divine creation that we know
of
[Music]
thank you